the value of architecture is practically
impossible to assess however one online
publication Barnett's
does publish ratings for German and
foreign architectural offices based on
the amount of trade press they've
received from its listings it's clear
that while the Bauhaus may be history
its principles still have considerable
influence for many years now Germany has
been best known for engineering
load-bearing construction and solar
technology for the down-to-earth side of
architecture rather than signature
design Germany has a reputation for
reliability and that draws in a lot of
business internationally the top Germans
in the international rankings are
gherkin margins partners the Bureau is
very big in German terms with over 500
staff GMP operates worldwide designing
and building museums stadiums and entire
cities like Ling gang in China the
architects pride themselves on having a
very distinct aesthetic our basic
philosophy is reducing function down to
what is absolutely necessary in all of
our buildings we always pare things down
to the absolute essentials but vous
n'etes as nationwide rankings are topped
by berlin-based bar coli bigger
architects lagina live eager and frank
Barco are very imaginative and
interdisciplinary in their approach very
much in keeping with the Bauhaus
tradition and they're no exception their
lagina liveing our believes German
architecture has many strengths German
architecture offices are very
detail-oriented and very advanced in
their use of engineering technology they
work closely with engineers for example
our office always works very closely
with innovative engineers developing
innovative concepts that happens on a
regular basis here in Germany but
Architects here don't necessarily stand
out in terms of bold design partly
because there aren't enough clients in
the world who want that but Germans are
more open in this respect than in other
countries this tall block is a stroke of
luck for Berlin which is otherwise
rather averse to high-rise architecture
it's a company headquarters built by
Barco Lavina in the capital's new europa
city development number two in germany
the starb architects office
the company has gained a reputation for
building museums often in historical
surroundings like the Minster Landis
Museum staff structures fit in there
conspicuously inconspicuous take for
example the restoration workshops of the
Prussian palaces and Gardens foundation
in Potsdam in the historical heart of
the city we're interested in buildings
that have their own contemporary
aesthetic but that also create a link to
the place or the history of the place in
that way they're more reserved than a
striking brand new construction would be
which some people might like to see in
such places for the Argon's hope const
museum on the baltic coast stab has
achieved a synthesis of distinctive
design and understatement the art
galleries elegant metal cladding will
change its color over time just like the
fact roofs of the northern German
farmhouses around it it's evolved in
close cooperation with specialists
mr. Dawkins in our strengths lie in the
precision of the finish or in the
detailed solutions we find including
technical solutions it's a cliche but we
Germans are definitely out front in that
respect
see abide fondant however there are very
few young architects represented in the
bow nets rankings in Germany many
clients are loath to take risks they're
not courageous enough to try out new
things to explore new avenues to
experiment young architects are probably
more suited to that kind of process
because they're still hungry I think
it's a hard profession it's quite
exploitative nevertheless I would advise
all young architects and I tell my
students that too to become
self-employed if they have the courage
the strength and the enthusiasm to do
that then they'll make it
[Music]